- This video is brought
to you by Fabulous.
(groovy music)
What's up, everybody? Michael here.
Now, today we're gonna reminisce
about the most convincing
fake ID of all time.
- You changed your name to McLovin?
- [Michael] "Superbad."
Now, the film was a hit
when it graced theaters
in all its horny glory in 2007,
and it pretty much holds up to this day,
delivering a nice balance
of hilarious moments
and painfully authentic
teenage mortification.
Still, "Superbad" is not a
film that at first glance
inspires extensive
philosophical speculation.
- Plus, you know, you scratch our backs,
we'll scratch yours.
- Well, Jules, the funny
thing about my back is,
is that it's located on my cock.
- But is there something
more profound to be said
about two high-school
seniors' mythic quest
to get wasted and boned?
And can this stoner flick
actually help us better understand
a classic German
philosophical disagreement
on the nature of consciousness?
You know we're gonna find out
in this "Wisecrack Edition
on 'Superbad': Deep or Dumb?"
And of course, major
spoilers ahead for the movie.
But before I get into it, I wanna tell you
about this video's sponsor, Fabulous.
If you ever have trouble
sticking to new routines
or if you're hoping to get a better grasp
on your day-to-day happiness,
Fabulous is the app for you.
It's a digital coach that
uses behavioral science
to help you create and
stick to good new habits.
Fabulous creates a
personalized daily routine
that can help you get on track
to achieve goals large and small,
whether it's to increase your productivity
or drink more water every day.
I'm using Fabulous to create
a good schedule for myself
'cause I struggle with balancing
a lot of different things
that I wanna do, and I think
Fabulous is gonna help me
have a well-thought-out structure
so I can do all the
things I'm excited about.
Now, the app helps you create
rituals throughout the day,
with small steps that help
you ease these new habits
into your life and can lead
to long-lasting changes.
You can choose between
two approaches on the app:
habit tracking or dedicated programs.
With the habit tracking approach,
you can go at your own pace as
you complete bite-sized tasks
and get gentle encouragement
throughout the day.
You can pick from 100 tasks
within the app or add your own.
Gonna add a couple things in
here right now. Okay. (sighs)
"Stop applying to be on
'American Ninja Warrior'
even though you've never
trained for a day in your life.
Go."
With the dedicated
programs, you're immersed
in a multi-league journey
of guided self-discovery.
Fabulous will spend you inspiring letters
with motivational advice inside,
and at the end of each letter,
you'll choose a positive
action for that week.
These new positive actions are
added to your daily routine,
and the app will send friendly reminders
to help you stick to them.
And with a Fabulous Premium account,
you can track an
unlimited number of habits
and access all the programs and exercises
the app has to offer.
Join the community
of more than 30 million
users around the world
and start building your
ideal routine today.
The first 100 people who click
on the link in the description
will get 25% off their
Fabulous subscription.
And now, back to the show.
Now, on its face, "Superbad"
definitely has all
the classic elements
of a dumb teen comedy.
You have two best friends
who are classic underdog virginal nerds
delusionally pursuing a vision
of drunken, sexed-up
glory at a crush's party.
- My older brother always says,
like, the nastiest (beep).
Like, he called me Hymen until I was 12.
Seth, I wanna blow you.
- Man, she didn't say that. Come on.
- [Michael] The pair secure
an invite to said party
by promising to provide the booze
via their friend's
totally realistic fake ID.
As they pursue these goals,
they'll inevitably learn
some important lessons
about life, friendship,
and drinking in moderation.
And of course, they'll encounter
some iconic gross-out comedic
scenarios along the way,
because that (beep) was just,
like, legally required in 2007.
- Someone perioded on my (beep) leg.
- Holy (beep). (laughing)
- What the (beep) do I do?
- [Michael] Indeed, "Superbad"
is a coming-of-age narrative
through and through, the
stoner cousin of stories
like "Pretty in Pink" or
"Call Me by Your Name."
But if you're a fan of the
movie, you may have noticed
it transcends some
limitations of the genre
by balancing top-notch
humor with genuine heart.
- I'm really sorry that
I blocked your cock.
- Apology accepted.
- Seriously, man.
- But is there depth beyond that?
To find out, we're gonna need to look
at an infamous debate between two big dogs
of German idealism, Hegel and J.G. Fichte.
Note that idealism is
the branch of philosophy
that basically wants to
figure out the ideal structure
of both reality and consciousness,
i.e., how does the world
work, how do our minds work,
and how do our minds work
when they're figuring
out how the world works?
Yeah, it took me years
to understand this stuff.
You might already know a bit about Hegel,
as he's one of our favorite
all-time philosophers.
He's remembered for his
master-servant dialectic,
which truly is a bad-vibes
name for a concept
if I've ever heard one.
For the uninitiated, the
dialectic is a form of reasoning
that begins with a contradiction
between a thesis and an antithesis
that's eventually if
only momentarily resolved
when they arrive at a
synthesis of the two.
Okay, for example, you could say
that there is an absolute contradiction
between consuming coffee
and falling asleep.
If your thesis is needing to sleep,
then chugging an espresso is going
to be antithetical to that.
But a synthesis would be the development
of something like decaf coffee,
which allows you to both
chug hot brown bean-water
and get a few hours of sleep.
Now, Hegel's dialectic of choice
was between a subjective
and objective spirit,
as outlined in his book "The
Phenomenology of the Spirit."
Fittingly for our purposes,
Hegel intended this book
to function as a sort of
philosophical coming-of-age story
about how human consciousness
or how your mind works.
In this case, though,
the spirit coming of age
is less concerned about
getting to third base
with the hottest girl in AP Calculus
and more concerned with
understanding itself
and properly relating to its
own internal contradictions.
Still, the parallels between "Superbad"
and "The Phenomenology of Spirit"
are actually a lot more substantial
than you might initially assume,
and considering them side
by side might help us
better understand both tales.
Now, Hegel's account of
the dialectic is supposed
to show how an independent
consciousness comes
to recognize itself as an individual
or as a subjective
consciousness with freedom
and capability, an individual
who can, like, do stuff.
At the beginning, Spirit is self-aware
but doesn't realize it is
differentiated from the world.
This is because it has never encountered
another conscious being like itself.
As a result, it has no
conception of the fact
that reality might not
begin and end with it.
It's narcissistic, I know.
Imagine a feral child,
abandoned in a forest,
living off nature, who somehow manages
to never encounter another
living conscious being
except for a bear who does
fun dance routines with it.
But then, suddenly, something happens.
Spirit encounters another
being just like itself,
a being who can see Spirit,
can recognize Spirit as
another conscious being.
By whatever extreme
coincidence, this being, too,
has never countered another
creature like itself.
Chaos is about to ensue.
You might remember a similar example
from classic Evan-tite Jean-Paul Sartre,
who talked about how it feels
when a creep is spying through a peephole
and all of a sudden sees
someone looking back at them,
calling their own
subjectivity into question.
You could loosely describe
a suburban high school
like the one in "Superbad"
as a sort of free-for-all
of developing spirits.
You know, a bunch of
smelly, narcissistic teens
encountering other
just like themselves in the
cafeteria and struggling
to recognize and understand
one another's consciousness.
All of this teenage
experimentation with identity
can be read as a bunch of
developing self-consciousnesses
trying to figure out
who the (beep) they are
and what the limits of their
freedom and consciousness are.
Also, lots of jerking off.
So what happens when two spirits meet?
According to Hegel,
they get super defensive
and try to kill the other guy,
sort of like the insecure teenager
who views the new kid
with cool hair, Devin,
as a threat to his own identity
as the school's number-one bad-boy type.
That's because being perceived
by someone else can be painful.
Realizing that you're not the
only conscious thing in town
makes you feel so insecure that you gotta
take out the other guy
to prove your dominance.
So basically, Spirit sometimes acts
like an insecure teenager.
Each consciousness wants to preserve
its own uniqueness and individuality
and sees violence as the
only way of doing this,
and so there follows a
struggle to the death.
- You better lawyer up, (beep),
'cause I'm not coming back for 30%.
I'm coming back for everything.
- [Michael] We see this
less dramatically rendered
in the ongoing struggle
between Seth and Evan,
who have each had to deal with the pain
of perceiving one another
and being perceived.
They both want and don't want to,
A, represent themselves
authentically to one another
and to, B, perceive one another's
representation accurately.
This inevitably results in conflict,
like how Evan conceals the fact
that he's going to room
with Fogell at Dartmouth
because he rightly thinks
it'll make Seth jealous.
- I didn't tell you because I, I thought-
- Because you're a backstabber
and you lied to your best friend
and you only wanna hang out with Fogell
and you just don't care anymore?
- But Hegel's described fight
between two consciousnesses
doesn't actually end in death.
Like two peacocking 16-year-old boys,
they're, for the most part, all talk.
That's because the winner realizes
that it can spare its opponent
and still be recognized as an individual.
How?
By making the defeated consciousness
its servant, of course.
But this, Hegel argued,
is an inherently unstable relationship.
It's not just that the servant
is hardly likely to be satisfied
with being forced to do
the master's bidding.
It's that the master's consciousness,
though technically the
strong and independent one,
is now entirely dependent on the servant.
Think back to another
classic high-school comedy
and the relationship between
Cady and Regina George,
in which the new-girl servant soon becomes
the protein-bar-wielding master.
Over time, the master
becomes completely reliant
on the servant to do stuff for them,
like a rich kid who moves to college
and asks when the maids will
be picking up his laundry.
The servant, ironically,
thus becomes stronger than the master.
If they ever realized this,
they would be able to rise
up and overthrow them,
and as such, things remain tense.
We see a sort of version of
this master-servant relationship
between Seth and Evan.
And also, um, I'll just say it.
It feels really weird
saying master in 2022,
so we're gonna call this
the Seth-Evan dialectic
from here on out.
Seth reads like the dominant
partner of the friendship,
gratuitously ripping on Evan.
- Do you think Becca's gonna be psyched
that you brought a bottle of lube?
"Oh, Evan, thank you for
bringing that lube for my (beep)!
I never would've been able to handle
your (beep) four-inch
(beep) inside my (beep)
without that gigantic bottle of lube!"
- [Michael] He's most comfortable
when he's bossing Evan around
and asserting his dominance.
But we see his domineering nature
is motivated by insecurity.
He's also brittle and jealous,
afraid of losing his power over Evan
as they transition into college.
- And I gotta look over at that.
Looks like the most fun I've
ever seen in my entire life.
- [Michael] Like most
cocky and brash teen boys,
all this attempted
dominance is, of course,
just a sign of his deep insecurity.
- So you're coming to
my party tonight, right?
'Cause it's, like, fully on.
- Yeah, why? Should I not come?
- [Michael] This manifests in his intense,
irrational dislike for
Evan's crush, Becca.
- Becca's a (beep).
- [Michael] It's also
visible in Seth's dismay
that Evan is going to room with Fogell.
- I didn't expect this from you, Evan.
Not from you.
Gimme that booze, (beep).
- We never should've had
to hide our arrangement.
- [Michael] While
functionally ruling over Evan,
he's also terrified of
being abandoned by him.
- No, I can't, I gotta
go meet my counselor.
I'm picking out my classes for next year.
- What, so I gotta sit
here and eat dessert alone
like I'm (beep) Steven Glanzberg?
- This suggests he needs Evan's deference
to feel fully recognized
in his own consciousness,
and if Evan fails to show that deference
or even just pay him enough attention,
Seth on some level knows he'll
lose all of his power and,
more importantly, all of
his value as an individual.
So how would Hegel resolve
this unstable relationship?
That is to say,
how would he reconcile
the Seth-Evan dialectic?
For Hegel, the submissive
member of the pair needs
to acquire an object which
it can express itself
in relation towards.
It's like how, when
your name is Seth Rogen
and you make a gorgeous
ashtray out of clay
for the 73 joints you smoke each day,
you can see some of your
consciousness manifested
in its trippy patterns, and
thus you become more aware
of your material ability
to impact the world.
Any time Rogen doubts his own
abilities, he can simply look
at all of the weed-consuming
accessories he's created
and think, "Wow, Seth,
you really did all this!"
Also, this third thing
mediates the relationship
between the dominant and
the submissive partners
and makes it so that they're no longer
completely dependent on one another.
And there is something of
this in "Superbad" as well.
Though they're still just kids
who can't really materially
impact the world around them,
they do indeed discover some third thing
to mediate their relationship through:
their fledgling romances
with Becca and Jules,
who we must say are of course
also individual self-consciousnesses
and ones that might seem to be even more
dialectically developed
than Seth and Evan.
Seth and Evan's struggle to get booze,
which leads them to crash an adult party
and do minor parkour and major a capella
while running from the cops,
is ultimately their quest to
actualize that third thing
via each one's romantic relationship,
and they spend the whole film
striving to achieve that.
Eventually, by entering this
romance, Evan comes to realize
that he is an independent actor from Seth.
By establishing these meaningful
relationships with others,
Evan and Seth are not only able
to be less puppishly
dependent on one another
but also to fully acknowledge
their very real love and friendship.
- I love you.
I love you, man.
- And key to leaving their
puppy-dog behavior behind
is that they have recognized
their dependence upon each other.
They recognize each other's consciousness
and how that consciousness is essential
to their own sense of self.
This is where Hegel's dialectic
can also be seen as a classical example
of the philosophical
concept of recognition,
that is, the idea that
we only become who we are
by being recognized as
such by those around us,
like through our relationships with others
and what we do in the world.
Having been fully
recognized by one another
for who they really are,
Seth and Evan are now ready
to go off to college as
independent young men.
They have been liberated
from their codependence
through their relationships with women.
Their friendship is now
no longer characterized
by necessity, but by freedom.
This means they are able to
want what's best for one another
and no longer seek to hold each other back
out of fear of losing an
essential part of themselves.
So already, we can see that
there's some genuine depth
to the way friendship is
portrayed in "Superbad."
But you're probably wondering:
Did we forget about Fogell
AKA McLovin's wild adventures
with the world's most incompetent cops?
Absolutely not.
And to understand his absurd storyline,
we need to return to
the idea of recognition,
a concept that Hegel
did not himself invent.
That credit is usually given
to his immediate predecessor,
J.G. Fichte, who Hegel
was directly responding to
in "The Phenomenology of Spirit."
Fichte's understanding of recognition
is pretty similar to Hegel's.
He also thinks that we become who we are
by being recognized as such by others.
But there's one key difference.
Hegel, as we have seen, thinks
that recognition is something
that can only be established
through a struggle,
but Fiche thinks the
process of recognition
is actually much more automatic.
For Fichte, one comes to be recognized
as an independent, autonomous individual
by being issued a summons from
another free, rational being.
Essentially, the summons is a command
which says, "You're
free, now act like it."
It's like how when you're a little kid,
your parents empower you
to act like a human being
by teaching you how
to, say, tie your shoes
and then expecting you
to do it on a daily basis
or switch to Velcro.
Over time, they'll likely summon you
to take on just about every
responsibility of adulthood
except probably paying
your own cell phone bill.
Thanks, Mom!
And if you ever kick
me off the family plan,
I swear to God you'll never see me again.
Fichte at one point even refers
to this process of summons
as equivalent to upbringing
or to the raising of a
child through community,
and he thinks that this summons
to be free is bound to
be issued to anyone,
just so long as they have a human body,
which brings us back to Fogell,
who experiences this Fichtean
style of recognition.
When the cops first see
Fogell in the liquor store,
they know his ID is a fake.
They know that McLovin
is the unconvincing alias
of a nerdy suburban kid who wants
to be a smooth, womanizing player.
- We know you're not 25, man.
We're not idiots, McLovin.
- Yeah.
- Did you know the whole time?
- [Michael] But they proceed
as if Fogell was who he
wants to be regardless.
They summon him to be a chill adult
shooting the (beep) with his
grossly negligent cop buddies.
And the extraordinary
thing about it is it works.
By being treated as if he was
a 25-year-old Hawaiian organ
donor with an air of danger
and a way with the ladies,
Fogell starts to act like it.
After being summoned by these goober cops,
he visibly gains confidence.
He even manages to hook up with a girl,
one who he had previously
struggled to even talk to.
- Uh, it's 10:33. (stammers)
- What?
- [Michael] In this way,
Fogell too experiences
an important sort of an
initiation into adulthood,
learning lessons that he
can use going forward.
That's even after the cops
reveal the inauthenticity
behind the whole night when they admit
they knew he was just a regular kid.
You can kinda see a Fichtean
style of recognition then
as the philosophy of "fake
it 'til you make it."
Notably, we learn that
Fogell's cop buddies
are also striving for their
own kind of recognition,
specifically, to be seen as cool cops.
- You know, cops can have
a fun time, too, you know?
- You know, in a way, I think
we wanted to show ourselves.
- So I guess you never really age out
of needing some good
old-fashioned recognition, huh?
And thanks in advance to
all the hip 21-year-olds
who don't ask me whose dad
I am when I'm at concerts.
It means a lot to my fragile geist.
So clearly Fichte's account
of recognition helps us
make sense of McLovin's wild ride.
But the question remains:
Which style of recognition
is more effective
in understanding the
development of consciousness,
Fichte's or Hegel's?
And to that end, is Fogell's
coming-of-age experience
as effective as Evan and Seth's?
Well, obviously Hegel was biased,
but he thought something was
missing from Fichte's account,
that is, the whole
struggle part you undergo
to achieve true recognition.
It's kinda like saying that
you can technically do sex
to yourself but it's probably going
to be a more fulfilling
experience if you do sex
with another freely willing
human consciousness.
See, through their struggle
to reconcile one another's consciousness,
Evan and Seth end the film as
serious, independent people.
Fogell, on the other hand, ends
it by destroying a cop car.
He is initiated into a
version of adulthood, sure.
Still, he seems imprisoned in a way
by the limitations of
his role models, who are,
by their admission, really
not good role models at all.
- [Michaels] He's not usually
this drunk when he does this,
but I think that could make it more cool.
- [Michael] Fogell doesn't go through
any dialectical struggle that teaches him
to become an independent person.
Instead, he morphs into a
ridiculous fantasy figure:
McLovin.
- Tight.
- If you're recognized for a
fantasy version of yourself,
are you really being recognized at all?
Hegel would probably say, "Nah, bro."
But, like, in German, obviously.
So in short, far from
being just silly, dumb fun,
"Superbad" starts to look
like an actually deep film
that manages to stage one of
the most important debates
in the history of German idealism
while averaging approximately
two dick jokes a minute.
- They literally made me stop eating foods
that were shaped like dicks.
No hot dogs. No Popsicles.
Do you know how many foods
are shaped like dicks?
The best kinds.
- By juxtaposing the
stories of Evan and Seth
and Fogell and McLovin,
"Superbad" actually shows
us why Hegel's account
of recognition might be
superior to Fichte's.
In this way, we see that we all could use
a little dialectical struggle of our own
to grow into truly
independent, conscious people.
But what do you think?
Is "Superbad" a successful illustration
of a tricky philosophical topic,
are its competing
coming-of-age narratives enough
to make it deep despite all
the talk about bodily fluids,
and is Hegel really
better than Fichte anyway?
Let us know in the comments.
Big thanks to our patrons for
recognizing our consciousness,
and be sure to check out
all the cool new perks
on our revamped Patreon page.
Also, don't forget to check out
our new stream, Wisecrack Live.
Happens right here every
Thursday at 11 a.m. Pacific.
Set fire to that subscribe
button like it's a cop car,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching. Later.
(upbeat music)